hello everyone and welcome to the game
you guys have been requesting ever since
it finished uh it's uh i mean and of
course for good reasons as usual it is
uh first board for the united states
fabiano corona versus first board for
india's second in india tomb
and it's uh the game everyone's pretty
much talking about i'm sure you guys
know how to finish but i'm not going to
spoil too much for those uh
who still i haven't heard the the news
but um
well fabius has been having an okay
event he lost two games so far he lost
to abdusatra when he lost to sergey of
armenia
uh and uh that that usually isn't that
big of a deal but for fabi who was you
know world number two for for a very
long time he's a former 2800 member uh
you don't expect him to lose two
classical games in a single event that's
uh this just doesn't happen very often
uh but still uh he mostly lost those
games he really tried to
he went over aggressive against
abdusatro and uh well uh sergio went all
in because he had to and he you know he
he
uh he got a good game out of it but okay
now uh we it's a different story it's
united states versus india too and uh
it's quite a beauty of a game let's
check it out fabi has the white pieces
and he opens with e4 we have c5 we
already know lukas goes for the sicilian
defense uh knight to f3 knight to c6 and
now bishop the b5 fabi goes for the
initial medina
attack we have g6 by gokush uh and now
we have castles bishop to g7 bishop
captain c6 b captures and rook to e1 so
this is all very very standard stuff
you've seen magnus cross and played this
with black many times on this channel
and you know on other places as well uh
and here queen the c7 it's a move that
isn't really uh
main here uh here knight h6 is a much
more common i2f6 also much more common
e5 much more common again we've seen
magnus play e5 here many times but here
we have queen to c7 and it is much much
rarer but not a surprise to fobby as
he is one of the most prepared players
in the world uh we have h3 here uh pawn
to d6 and here comes ponte e5 uh
grabbing more space in the center and
this is basically a new move uh uh that
uh
that was ever played here and no one
ever played e5 in this position uh it
has been reached many times for example
c3 has been played he's been played by
dubois he's been played by adiban he's
been played by abdusatro he's been
played uh magnus cross and defeated
anish giri in the 2019 edition of the
tata still india rapid edition so c3 is
the moon that was played here but e5 is
a new move so already as of 8 we have a
completely new game fabi tries to
surprise the gookash and let's see how
it uh how it goes uh the counters on e5
of course you can see that it's upon
sacrifice white cannot recollect the
pawn is defended by the bishop and by
the queen uh so lukas now is up upon but
he has a double c pawn and he has a
double e pawn so what does fabi have in
mind here he goes d3 uh prepares the uh
the develop the bishop go after that c5
pawn and here goku immediately gives it
back just c4 says all right if you want
to capture it you can but if you grab
the pawn this way then you have a double
c pawn
now i'm going to play a fight and then
my position is just great here but fabi
didn't play this to recollect pawns he
goes knight to c3 and now c captures on
the three c captures and now knight to
h6 a very interesting decision by goku
giving up the pawn right away
he could continue with something like
bishop to e6 or even bishop to f5 but he
goes for activity uh
instead of safeguarding his material and
okay fabi grabs the the pawn back knight
captures on e5 this
is made possible by the knight now being
on h6 as if the bishop captures then the
knight is no longer defended so knight
stay five goku's not counting pawns here
we have bishop to f4 uh preparing some
nasty discoveries towards google's queen
and queen to be
putting pressure on the b2 pawn and fabi
just plays knight to a4 so the b two
bone is nicely defended then you
constantly have to worry about what if
the knight comes to c5 as it will come
with a great tempo so f6 bookish kicks
away the knight here
this is your option basically if you
don't play it then the knight remains on
e5 i mean and you don't want this knight
here so knight back to f3 and here
bookish castles we have pawn to d4 by
fabi and now onto g5 chasing away the
bishop bishop to h2 and now comes age
five bucasha goes all in against fabi
he's already on seven out of seven he
has nothing to prove and it went well
for sargeant when sergio and charged
with the white pieces against fabi with
g for h4
uh so uh how can fabi react to this well
he plays rook to e4 very nicely done uh
just regards that g4 square and the the
entire fourth rank and lukas plays queen
to d7
uh it seems like you can maybe play c5
uh open up a discovery towards the rook
but it doesn't work because knight
captures here just attacks the queen and
the defends the rook and even if queen
captures on b2 then d5 comes and now
white's position is just much much
better so booker says all right queen to
d7 and now we have queen to c2 uh now
fob is ready to go after that c6 pawn we
have rooked the f7 uh
seemingly over defending the e7 uh d7
pawn but it it all comes with a very
good reason we have rook 8 the e1 now
putting pressure on e7 and now the
f5 this is a this is an incredibly
classy move by google because if you
look at the position now it's very very
hard to
find an actual good move for google for
example if you you can't go rook to b8
even though you really want to because
of the bishop on h2 i know you guys
forgot about the bishop don't lie uh and
also if you try something like bishop to
a6 then you just allow knight to see
five attacks the bishop and the queen
yeah it's just i mean the queen goes
here rook to e6 that one's the
knighthood c5 and the rook the e6 this
is just resides for black so it is
incredibly difficult for lukas to make
an active move here and bishop to f8 is
actually a really really good idea so
here fabi goes queen to e2 puts even
more pressure on the e7 pawn and now
comes queen to d5 now putting pressure
on that a2 phone so knight to c3 attacks
the queen and defends the a2 pawn and
queen back to b7 and now fabi has to
make a choice and it is a choice that
could uh
very well be uh well the difference
between losing this game and winning
this game and here fabi plays queen to
c4 he uh grabs hold of this diagonal
but the really tricky idea that fabi
could have gone for is knight characters
on g5 so the idea is that after f
captures you will capture an h5 so you
grab two points for the piece you start
an attack against the black king and
it's not all that clear how black should
continue it is the g5 pawn is hanging if
you go the ship to h6 then even rook to
e6 is possible uh white will have an
excellent game here so this is uh this
was in the position for fabi but i
believe
uh since fabio already lost two games he
doesn't wanna over push it and maybe he
doesn't trust himself to to play a move
like this so instead he played queen to
c4 which is also a very good move and
now bukash goes queen to visa again put
pressure on the b two pawn floppy plays
b4 gets the pawn out of harms away and
now quanta e6 forever getting rid of
that weakness on e7 uh rook to b1 by
fabi and now queen the d7 fabio repeats
rule b to e1 with queen to be seven rook
to b1 and now queen to d7 uh mukesh
offers a draw basically if fabi repeats
rook t1 then we will have a draw by
three for the repetition and here fabi
decided that uh he needs to play on he
played a3 and the game now continues and
this gives bulkach a whole new idea on
how to activate it the rook on a8
because like we said you can't go to b8
so he plays a5 and this is uh
uh the start of uh
of uh incredibly precise moves by by
both players so here okay of course he
wants to open up the a file we have
knight to a4 i'm going for that c5
square and now yeah you can capture on
b4 also like the basics is a possibility
just working your queen in the rook so
here queen to d8 uh guarding b6 and now
b captures on a5 uh we have rook
captures on a5 by goku and knight to c5
fabi gets his knife to this beautiful
active c5 square but now luke has just
placed queen to d5 and he asks fabi what
do you play here
uh and it's not it's not easy to find a
move here because if fabi trades queens
for example queen captures on b5 c
captures the rook is attacked you have
to move the route back now bishop
captures on c5 and you will pick up the
a3 pawn for example the capture through
captures an a3 or even better rook
characters on c5 and uh lukas will be up
upon and with the material traded down
chances are that fabi will lose this
game or you know maybe with perfect play
he can save it so fabi says all right
i'm gonna lose the pawn either way so at
least let's keep the queens on the board
let's keep the game uh complicated maybe
i can go for some sort of an attack and
he goes back queen to e1 now you know
that once the knight moves maybe you can
go after the h5 pawn maybe you can open
up the black king so here rook captures
an a3 bookish accepted the pawn
and rook to d1 now adding more uh
defense to this d4 pawn we have rook
after a7 now with access to the a2
square attacking the queen you can also
play rook to a1 if you want to trade
rooks put pressure on the back rank and
now finally we have g4 by fabi chasing
away the knight from from f5 with h
characters and g5 for h characters and g
for and now knight to the h6 putting
pressure on this g4 pawn and now bishop
to g3 now now you can maybe move the
king maybe you can bring the rook into
the attack maybe something good will
happen but here luke is just uh
completely opens up the position he
plays e5 and now fabi is without a move
basically uh now the the attack on the
g4 pawn is opened up uh the attack on
the d4 point is happening you you can
never capture an e5 if you capture here
you just wonder a knight uh so uh what
can fabi play here
what what he could play is knight to the
h2 but it's not all that great yes your
g4 pawn is nicely defended but not just
rook a1 you attack the rook and it
doesn't really matter how white replies
to this black's position is just winning
for example if queen e1 you go after dru
who can we can happily trade here
captures captures and just bishop
captures on c5 white can never recapture
as the queen on d1 would hang so instead
after this e5 move bobby says all right
i have one more idea that i can try and
that is knight captures on e5 fabi gives
up a piece uh the clears to clear some
squares in front of the black king to go
for the attack uh but lukas just plays
it to perfection f captures on e5 we
rook captures on e5 and now it seems
like uh fabi is breaking through it
seems like the attack is happening but
there is one move that lukas can play uh
that forces poppy to resign the game so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the only move that wins the
game for lukas while i give you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on realizing that you
are up material and if your opponent
wants to trade queens that's exactly
what you should do and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
bishop
and g4 this is what lukish played and
now there really isn't uh a move for
fabi here uh the problem is you can't
trade queens if you trade queens queen
captures knight captures rook captures
uh you already sacrificed material
you're down a full rook of course you
cannot play this this is instant resign
so after bishop captures on g4 bobby
played queen to b2 he keeps the queens
on the board still attacks the wooker's
queen and goes after the g5 pawn it
seems incredibly scary but lucas shows
that there is nothing to worry about and
uh there are many ways to win the game
here uh google goes for the uh for the
bravest attempt and that is queen to f3
and now bookish is saying i'm just going
to play russia up to h3 and checkmate
your king how are you stopping this uh
and okay fabi has the one capture that
he can go for queen captures and g5 uh
but that's not really the the greatest
one uh he played rook captures on g5
because if queen captures you just block
with rook to g7 and now everything is
attacking the white king there's really
nothing here if you capture on h6 uh
your rook is hanging on d1 let's not
forget about that queen captures king g2
now bishop to f3 check and you get
checkmated king h3 queen to h1 with
check and of course that's it bishop hq
queen g2 check uh king to h4 and now
queen captures on h2 will be a very very
forced checkmate in line so after queen
to f3 uh we have uh rook captain g5 by
fabi but now again just rook to g7 we
have rooked at e1 and now we have the
shuffle h3 bookish not interested in
anything fabi's doing he's just going
for checkmate and now fabi the only way
for fabi to defend this is to move the
bishop so the rook controls the g2
square here fabi plays bishop to d6 but
other moves really don't help
uh again google finds the absolute
cleanest way to end the game bishop
captures on d6 rook captures on g7 with
king captures and queen the g5 check now
king to h7 and now knight to e4 hoping
to get some knight to f6 action in uh
but luke is just in the game on the spot
he plays queen capture 74 sacrifices his
queen and he was in this position on 45
that fabiano corwana resigned it again
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh fabi is down too much material and if
the queen is accepted then goku has a
very simple rook day one check and look
at this the bishop player from hell
doing uh one hell of a job here there is
nowhere for the king to move once you
give up all of your pieces then it will
be checkmate with real capture sunny one
and that's basically that's why fabio
resigned the game so after queen
captures on e4 we can see it once again
in slow motion look at this queen
captures on e4 fabio resigns lukash is
on eight out of eight this is incredible
stuff uh it's uh you know people say
that it's silly to even talk about the
uh rating performances with perfect
scores because google's on eight out of
eight here i i haven't checked but he
could be like a 3300 rating performance
i don't know it's i mean
incredible stuff but i mean perfect
score
after eight games after facing fabiano
corona uh it is definitely something i
haven't expected i i know he's been
having like an incredible tournament
he's been approaching every game uh with
such ingenuity he's been very very
original in his preparation going for
lines that carlson and dubo play which
are incredibly sharp and incredibly
tactical
and uh
i mean it's just okay i thought he's in
seven out of seven he had a good run now
he has black against fabi if he fights
well okay maybe he can get a draw but
getting a win here and going on eight
out of eight uh with three more rounds
in the olympia
there it actually actually exists a
possibility for him finishing on 11 out
of 11. of course it feels like you might
be jinxing it but uh
i mean he just beat fabi with black
after i mean in round eight of the
olympia he's an eighth out of it it is a
possibility it's definitely a
possibility i mean there's no greater
opponent than fabi here in the olympia
uh so yeah uh that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it really incredible stuff
i can't um you know stop praising lucas
but uh i mean he he's been playing such
such incredible chess that i'm sure you
guys uh
agree that uh you know it's uh
it's not misplaced uh and if you guys
are interested in the in the in the uh
story about it being uh so small there
are still 39 players on the uh on the
uh feed a uh only 2 700 players so you
can see that crosstalk is still uh in
the top uh but lukas has jumped all the
way to number 20. he's currently number
28 20 on the live ratings list he has
earned 30 rating points uh since uh the
last account uh which is just incredible
you can see how difficult it is to
actually gain waiting points you can see
that everyone's either on zero not
playing or uh on minus uh and uh well
okay there there's
he's doing very well he's a plus 13 and
a half but other than that no one is in
the plus double digits except uh except
30 points so when you're over 2700
that's uh
not something that happens
had an incredible run when he broke the
2800 barrier i think he also won some 20
something points but other than that i
haven't seen that in a very very long
time
uh so yeah okay enough phrasing there
are still more games to cover and still
more games for bookish to be won uh but
i mean uh well i believe the praise was
well deserved
uh so that's the game and a little bit
of extra info regarding the olympia if
you guys uh really want to know uh india
too has defeated the united states uh in
the match uh so i hope you guys uh
enjoyed that as well
one on board one and i believe also on
board for
uh there was a decisive result i haven't
checked yet but i can check like really
really quickly so let me just uh do this
yeah okay
uh
yeah
one on board one uh sareen uh drew
against taranyan pragyananda drew
against wesley and ronak sadwani
defeated linear dominguez perez so
incredibly incredible run for india too
who are definitely in contention for
winning the entire team
uh so once again really hope you guys uh
enjoyed it um
uh
i would like to thank braxton reynolds
uh and joshua hadley for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
olympiad until it finishes so thank you
all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day